it is the final week now to get in your
nomination for a remarkable woman in our
community someone who you know who's
making a positive difference in the
lives of others now this person could
end up receiving ten thousand dollars
for the charity of her choice here's
Kirsten Joyce
2019 we here at Channel 8 along with our
parent company next star have been
recognizing amazing women in our
communities like Kathleen Miller who
opened a faith-based house for homeless
teens and women who are pregnant or have
young kids and in the last couple of
weeks I've heard from three of them that
have stopped by to just to say hello to
check on me to let me know how they're
doing this is the story of a woman who's
dedicated her life to others you've
written in detailing these women's
groundbreaking efforts Diane orgill a
teacher for two decades who then helped
create the very first Spay and Neuter
Clinic in Las Vegas and then became a
volunteer with the American Red Cross
helping people during their Darkest
Hours I saw on TV there were fires in
California and there were people wearing
red cross vests working with the horses
so I called and I said I want to do your
animal thing some like Maggie Carlton
from humble beginnings to eventually
becoming the longest serving female
lawmaker in our state a lot of it had to
do with being a working mom who wanted
to represent folks from the perspective
of a working home we walk the frontier
picket line uh on Fridays and I took my
daughters down there to walk and pick it
up Marissa Hawkins brought together
businesses to honor Health Care Heroes
at the height of the pandemic we never
want our Healthcare Heroes to ever
forget that they were instrumental in
keeping our community alive and healthy
ultimately it was Christian Schuler
Heintz the remarkable woman from Las
Vegas is Kristen Schuler Heights
congratulations
[Applause]
I'm chosen to represent Las Vegas thanks
to her tireless efforts to keep people
from being evicted from their homes